depuis 1963 à l'accès du grand public
aux peintures rupestres de la grotte de
lascaux est fermé en raison des
dégradations apparu sur les oeuvres et
bien de nouvelles moisissures ont été
constatées récemment sur le site
elles ont poussé des spécialistes à
concevoir un outil qui teste
virtuellement l'influencent de l'air et
de l'humidité comme nous l'expliquent
patrick esther eric chaney derrière
cette porte blindée la grotte de lascaux
bain de désinfectant obligatoire pour
les chaussures un maximum de précautions
semblaient prises pour préserver ce
patrimoine de l'humanité
ses peintures témoignent de la vie
d'homme présents ici il y a plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'années mais
aujourd'hui ces peintures de nouveaux
sont gravement malades
menacé par un réchauffement climatique
locale à partir du moment où cette
grotte a été découverte et on s'est
introduit dans le milieu on a provoqué
des perturbations de cet équilibre
naturel
le problème actuel de la grotte de
lascaux c'est la prolifération de
champignons depuis 2001 et cette
prolifération de champignons elle est
due à un déséquilibre climatique
épandage de chaux vive sur le sol
compresses de fongicides et
d'antibiotiques sur les peintures la
guerre a été déclarée aux moisissures
blanches responsables de ces tâches le
fusarium solani récemment d'autres
taches noires sont apparues pour voler
au secours de la grotte malade il
fallait mieux comprendre les
perturbations son atmosphère et pour
cela avoir recours à un simulateur
numérique afin de recréer virtuellement
le comportement et gros thermique de la
grotte et son interaction avec
l'environnement
voici par exemple comment la seule
présence d'un homme avec la chaleur
qu'il dégage modifie la circulation de
l'air il s'agit d'un doux vrai défi
scientifique parce que les phénomènes
physiques sont assez complexes à
représenter la géométrie est elle aussi
complexe puisque c'est une cavité avec
une très grande dimension
dans un premier temps ça va permettre de
comprendre les phénomènes qui sont
présents dans dans la cavité puis a
ensuite de les quantifier et enfin
d'apporter des solutions à bon escient
ça nous permet par exemple de vérifier
quel est l'impact de l'introduction
d'une cloison ou de la suppression d'une
cloison la modification d'un système de
régulation de la température etc choc de
civilisations l'ordinateur du 21e siècle
va peut-être permettre de sauver des
peintures vieille de 200 siècles